hi everyone
this is professor m science and today i
want to talk about
unitary operators in another one of our
videos on rigorous quantum mechanics
unitary operators are used for many
different purposes in quantum mechanics
for example spatial translations or time
evolution
are described by unitary operators as
another example
the symmetry operations of a hamiltonian
can be represented by a group
of unitary operators the aim of today's
video is to go over the basic
mathematical properties of unitary
operators so we can use them confidently
when we need to
let's go a unitary operator u
is an operator whose inverse is equal to
its adjoint
and the definition is as simple as that
in the rest of the video we'll explore
the properties of operators that obey
this relation
but before we do that let's rewrite the
definition in another way that is also
typically used
remember that the inverse of an operator
is such that when we multiply them
together
in either order we obtain the identity
for unitary operators this means that u
dagger u is equal to uu dagger
which is equal to the identity this
equation is a restatement of the fact
that u dagger is equal to the inverse of
u
the first property of unitary operators
that we're going to look at
is that the product of two unitary
operators is also unitary
to see this consider a unitary operator
u
another unitary operator v and the
product uv
to check that uv is also unitary we
first consider uv dagger times uv
we know that the adjoint of a product of
two operators is equal to the product of
the add joints in reverse order
and we get v dagger u dagger u v
as u is unitary this is the identity
and we get v dagger v and as v is
unitary
this also gives the identity we could
similarly show that
u v times u v dagger is also equal to
the identity
and putting these results together we
see that uv is unitary
this confirms that the product of two
unitary operators
is itself a unitary operator
now i want to consider the eigenvalue
equation of unitary operators
we can write it as u lambda equals
lambda lambda
where as usual the lambda here is the
eigenvalue and the lambda here the
eigenstate
we've been working a lot with hermitian
operators in our study of quantum
mechanics
and in that case the eigenvalues are
real numbers
however for a general non-hermitian
operator like the unitary operators
we're looking at today
the eigenvalues don't have to be real
numbers and in general they'll be
complex numbers
to figure out the eigenvalues let's
consider the norm squared of u lambda
we can use the eigenvalue equation to
write this as the norm squared of lambda
lambda we can expand the norm as the bra
times the ket
remembering to take the complex
conjugate of the lambda associated with
the bra
assuming that the eigenstates are
normalized then we end up with the
absolute value squared of lambda
let's now write the norm squared again
we now first expand in terms of the bra
and the ket as u is unitary
we end up with lambda lambda which
equals 1.
putting these results together we get
that the absolute value squared of
lambda is equal to 1.
this means that the eigenvalues of a
unitary operator
are numbers of magnitude 1. we can write
any number of magnitude 1 as this
exponential
where phi lambda is a real number
so the eigenvalues of unitary operators
are in general complex numbers but their
magnitude must be equal to 1.
this is quite different to what we know
about the eigenvalues of hermitian
operators
which can take any value but they must
be real numbers
still working with the eigenvalue
equation the next thing i want to show
is at the eigenstate of unitary operator
that corresponds to different
eigenvalues are orthogonal
to do so we start again with the
eigenvalue equation of a unitary
operator u
the first thing we need to show is that
this implies that the bra lambda u
is equal to the eigenvalue times the bra
lambda
to see this we start with the eigenstate
lambda
we then insert the identity we can write
out the identity as u dagger u because u
is unitary
this here is the eigenvalue equation for
u so we get
lambda u dagger lambda using the result
from the previous slide that lambda is a
number of magnitude 1
we can rewrite this as the exponential
of i phi lambda times u dagger lambda
we can then isolate this term and get u
dagger lambda
equal to the exponential of minus i phi
lambda times lambda this is just the
complex conjugate of the original
exponential
so we can rewrite this expression as the
complex conjugate of lambda
times lambda the final step is to
convert this latest equation to the
joule space
to get this and as usual we got this by
turning all cats into brass
here and here all scalars into their
conjugates
here and all operators into their
adjoints here
this completes the proof of this
relation up here and we're now ready to
show that the eigenstates are orthogonal
let's first make some room we consider
two eigen states of u
the first lambda a base d eigenvalue
equation
and the second mu a base this other
eigenvalue equation
for the second one we'll also make use
of the corresponding equation
for brass we've just derived
okay we're now ready for the proof first
we calculate the bracket
mu u lambda using this eigenvalue
equation
in this part here gives lambda mu lambda
we can write the bracket again and now
we use this expression here
in this part here and we end up with mu
mu lambda
subtracting these two equations gives
that zero
equals lambda minus mu times the bracket
mu lambda
this means that if lambda is not equal
to mu
then this bracket must be zero and
that's it
the eigenstates of a unitary operator
corresponding to distinct eigenvalues
are orthogonal
up to this point we've investigated the
fundamental properties of unitary
operators that follow from their
definition up here
in the rest of the video we'll look into
what happens when we apply a unitary
operator
to a quantum state or to another
operator
this process of applying a unitary
operator is called a unitary
transformation
a key reason why unitary operators are
so important in quantum mechanics
is that unitary transformations conserve
the scalar product
let's consider a ket psi 1 prime equal
to the action of a unitary operator u
on a ket psi 1. this is an example of a
unitary transformation
between the state psi 1 and the state
psi 1 prime
we can do the same with another state
si2 prime which is the unitary
transformation of the state
psi 2. we now ready to prove that
unitary transformations conserve the
scalar product
to do so let's consider the scalar
product between psi 1 prime
and site 2 prime we can rewrite it in
terms of the unitary transformation
of the bra of psi 1 remembering to take
the adjoint of u and going to dual space
and then the unitary transformation of
psi 2. this here is now the identity
operator because u is a unitary operator
and we get the bracket psi 1 psi 2.
this confirms that the scalar product of
the primed states
is equal to the scalar product of the
original states
okay this is the key where we care so
much about unitary transformations in
quantum mechanics
they conserve the scalar product
it immediately follows that they also
conserve the norm of gets
because the norm is simply the scalar
product of a ket with itself
so that means that applying a unitary
transformation allows us to change a
state without changing its normalization
a well-known example of this is the time
evolution of a quantum state
which is a process that conserves the
norm and can be described by a unitary
operator
called the time evolution operator we
actually have a video on the time
evolution operator
so if you want to learn more about it
just follow the link in the description
and before we move on a quick aside
you're most likely familiar with
orthogonal transformations
in say a three-dimensional real vector
space examples of orthogonal
transformations include rotations
or reflections about a point or a plane
and for 3d vectors they are
transformations that conserve
the scalar product in this language
unitary transformations are simply the
generalization
of orthogonal transformations from real
to complex vector spaces
we're next going to extend unitary
transformations to operators
using a similar primed notation to the
one we've used for cats
we say that the unitary transformation
of an operator a
is given by another operator a prime and
what we need to decide now is what we
mean by unitary transformation in the
case of operators
to do so we first need to consider a
basis v
of state space and also the
corresponding basis v
prime obtained by the unitary
transformation of v
we then say that the operator a prime is
a unitary transformation
of the operator a if the matrix elements
of a
prime in the v prime basis are the same
as the matrix elements of a in the v
basis
this definition is typically rewritten
in a more convenient form
and to see it let's consider again the
matrix element of a prime
in the v prime basis what we do now is
to use the fact that the v prime states
are the unitary transforms of the v
states and we can then spell out this
matrix element
as v n u dagger a prime u vm
combining these two expressions and as
vn and vm are arbitrary base states
then we have that a is equal to u dagger
a prime u working with this last
equation
let's first pick the left hand side and
multiply from the left by u
and from the right by u dagger to get
this
picking the right hand side we can again
multiply by u from the left
and u dagger from the right and as u is
unitary we have an identity here
and another one here and we end up with
a prime
this is the key equation when we build
the operator a prime
as equal to u a u dagger then we say
that a prime
is the unitary transformation of a
okay this is just a definition and i do
realize that at this point it may sound
somewhat abstract
however we encounter unitary
transformations of operators very often
in quantum mechanics usually in the
context of symmetry
and you can find a very simple example
of this in the video on even
and odd operators
let's now explore some properties of
unitary transformations of operators
first i want to show that if a is a
hermitian operator
then its unitary transformation is also
hermitian
to see this consider a prime dagger
we can now expand a prime in terms of
its unitary transformation
the adjoint of a product is the product
of the adjoint in reverse order
and it is simply the definition of the
unitary transformation of a dagger
additionally if a is hermitian then we
can write this as the unitary
transformation of
a and therefore a prime dagger is equal
to a
prime if a is hermitian confirming our
original claim
second let's consider the nth power of
the unitary transformation of
a we can write a prime in terms of
a we can now explicitly write the n
terms in the power
all the terms u dagger u give the
identity
and we have this u here that we copy
here
then we have n factors of a and then
this u dagger here
which we copy here by definition this is
simply the unitary transformation
of a to the power n and this means that
the power of unitary transformation here
is equal to the unitary transformation
of the power here
we can do more as functions of operators
are defined through their power series
then this result implies that the
unitary transformation of the function
of an operator
is equal to the function of the unitary
transformation of the operator
and third let's consider the eigenvalue
equation under unitary transformation
consider an operator a with its
eigenvalue equation
we now look at the action of the unitary
transformation of a
acting on the unitary transformation of
the eigenstate
using the definitions of unitary
transformations we can write out a prime
like this
and alpha prime like this
this here is now the identity and we get
u
a alpha this is now the eigenvalue
equation of
a and we get alpha u alpha
and this is the unitary transformation
of alpha so we end up with
alpha alpha prime so what does this mean
if we have an eigenvalue equation for an
operator a
then a unitary transformation means that
the eigenstates of
a prime are the transformed eigenstates
of a
here and here and the eigenvalues
stay the same
up to this point we've discussed the
fundamental properties of unitary
operators and we've also looked at
unitary transformations of states and
operators
the last thing i want to do is to
discuss two useful ways of working with
unitary operators
the first concerns their relation to
hermitian operators
and the second looks at infinitesimal
unitary operators
let's start with the relation between
hermitian and unitary operators
let a be a hermitian operator and we now
define a new operator t
as equal to the exponential of i a
i now claim that this operator t is a
unitary operator
to see this consider first the adjoint
of t
explicitly we get the adjoint of the
exponential
using the power series of an exponential
we can expand it like this
we can now apply the add joint
calculating the complex conjugate of all
scalars and the adjoint of all operators
and it is simply the exponential of
minus i a dagger
as a is hermitian then it is simply the
exponential of minus i
a it is now trivial to see that t
dagger t equals this
and that a commutes with itself that is
simply the identity
and conversely t t dagger
equals this which is also equal to the
identity
these two relations imply that t is
unitary
we often encounter this form in quantum
mechanics where a unitary operator is
given by the exponential
of i times the hermitian operator as we
have up here
as an example you can check out our
video on the translation operator t
alpha which is the operator that
translates a position eigenstate
by an amount alpha it is a unitary
operator that has this exponential form
and the corresponding hermitian operator
is the momentum operator here
and the final thing i want to discuss is
the infinitesimal unitary operator
we consider unitary operator u that
depends on a small parameter
epsilon which is a real number
we then say that u epsilon is an
infinitesimal operator
and what we mean is that u epsilon tends
to the identity operator
as epsilon tends to zero we can expand u
epsilon in a power series with the first
term being the identity
the second being epsilon times some
other operator g
and so on if we consider the adjoint
operator
we can expand it in an equivalent power
series
and we have epsilon rather than its
conjugate here because epsilon is real
we can now calculate u epsilon times u
dagger epsilon
and using the expansions we get first
the identity
then epsilon times g plus g dagger
and then the remaining terms are higher
powers of epsilon
as u epsilon is unitary then this whole
series must equal the identity operator
this means that the higher order terms
here must vanish
and for the first or the term this means
that g plus g dagger
vanishes this implies that g is equal to
minus
g dagger which means that g is
anti-hermitian
it is typically convenient to define a
new operator f
as equal to ig with this definition
the anti-hermitian relation for g
becomes this
which implies that f is hermitian this
means that we can
always write an infinitesimal unitary
transformation like this
where the operator f is hermitian
conversely this means that if we have an
expression like this where f is
hermitian
then the operator u here is unitary
again this may seem somewhat abstract at
this point but infinitesimal unitary
transformations are very useful
you can find an example of this in the
video on the time evolution operator
which is a unitary operator that
describes the time evolution of quantum
states
and an infinitesimal time evolution is
given by this expression
where the infinitesimal parameter is dt
and the hermitian operator
is the hamiltonian
let's finish with a quick recap a
unitary operator
is an operator whose adjoint is equal to
its inverse
as shown by these two equivalent
relations in the top row
the eigenvalues of a unitary operator
are scalars of magnitude 1
so we can write them like this for the
eigenstates
if they correspond to different
eigenvalues lambda and mu
then they are orthogonal beyond these
fundamental properties
we've then considered unitary
transformations which describe what
happens when we apply unitary operators
to states
or to operators the key property of
unitary transformations of states
is that they preserve the norm
finally we've discussed how we can write
the unitary operator t
as an exponential where a here is a
hermitian operator
and also how we can write an
infinitesimal unitary operator like this
where
f here is again a hermitian operator
this was a pretty long and mathematical
video but it is essential that we
understand the properties of unitary
operators
they feature in many problems and if you
want to see them in action
check out our videos on the translation
operator or on the time evolution
operator both of which are unitary
operators
and as always if you liked the video
please subscribe